the whole plane was sleep and I seen
Cobra over there he was like three
worlds over but so he's way on the other
side but I just seen him Bob in his head
with headphones on but when I go over
there he's got a piece of scratch paper
with like 30 different little quartz on
it it blew me away it was like a
beautiful mind like he wanted to be the
best and he did everything he could
[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Thomas dopasiola
whatever you want to call me this is the
dope as usual podcast I'm here with my
co-host Martian what's up guys what's up
guys this is dope Fusion podcast here to
talk about live drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between today you guys have been bugging
and it's finally here this is the Matt
Barnes episode thanks for being here
fellas thank you for having me man
appreciate to be here good to be here
and only guess I see rolls up with their
own joint yeah joints is that a glass of
ginger ale it is I haven't had no food
yet so I figure I'm gonna smoke and I'm
probably gonna hit Tito's Tacos after we
get hot and then just go finish off my
desk Tacos yeah where's that what's that
you know you're not familiar oh you
gotta hit Tito said solid I prefer
Ramona's potatoes is on the way home I
never heard none of these yeah before
yeah I always said I'm from Merced okay
so I moved down here oh you're up north
guy yeah I'm from the valley I'm sack so
yeah no he was telling me he's like yeah
the area I had no idea you were from the
same spot so you remember I always get
off the start you remember when the weed
just disappeared When what when we just
disappear oh yeah in 2011. problem all
right so you're from up here okay all
right all right see it's different when
you're from that area
Sac right now I'll just say is is
booming on the production side of like
legal weed right now it is the [__] well
there's so much now I feel like it's
like it's a watered-down market the
market got water down yes because
there's just so much now so it was such
a hot thing what three years ago maybe
three years ago do you remember and it's
been main I mean up north we've been
doing it for a long time whatever you
know all right we're gonna smoke yeah
let's cheers and what do we got here uh
this is a man this is a seven leaves
pre-rolled uh the Sacramento Kings theme
uh the Kings have a theme called light
the beam when they win
um so we made some pre-rolls with you
know a company on part of seven leaves
so just I'm not normally a pre-roll guy
oh seven leaves yeah this has been a
minute though yeah I've been seven weeks
since like 17 2017. yeah oh all right so
yeah were they working with my guys that
was going on is that part with that
connection what it was yeah oh okay okay
so I'm not normally a pre-roll guy but
these ones aren't bad so I don't do
pre-rolls often yeah me neither I'm
usually their heart is a rock I normally
fresh roll my [__] but a joints your
main thing huh yeah I was a I mean I
smell swishers for like 20 something
years and I was hanging out with whiz
one day and he finally convinced me to
try papers and I tried them and I never
went back so that was probably like in
2015 maybe 2016 so I've been paper since
did it affect your cardio I didn't know
it did because I was smoking Swisher so
I was just I've been smoking swishes
since I was 14 so I just didn't really
know what free lungs were like until I
got on papers and then after that I'm
like holy [__] there's not a cloud oh my
God it's not an absolutely there's not a
cloud on my chest no more stop smoking
Swisher's uh the winner you ever get
that oh nasty every time you wake up
it's a horrible nasty yeah I don't even
smoke if I can't smoke I don't really do
back well I don't do nothing but papers
now so safe I don't smoke nothing but
papers a hemp wrap if if
Dives and audibles and stuff where you
stand on that I need to learn them a
little bit better you know I mean I'm
not at dabs I've tried a few dabs dabs
are just not my game like I like to like
I like the process of getting high yeah
you know you have to when you put it out
write it right like you know what you're
gonna get with Edibles and dabs just or
well particularly with dabs it's too
fast and then Edibles I just don't
really understand the micro dosing of
what my body can handle so it differs
man I'm a little too old to be venturing
out there not just you know I'm a 43 now
I don't think you are man I think you're
cheap I want to try it I just have to
know what I'm getting into all right so
how about this next time I come on
Wednesday I'm Gonna Leave something on
your desk right here yeah try that okay
try the Edibles Edibles and I'll leave
you do you [__] like electronic rigs
I'll try it try that way you don't have
to hit the torch it's not all high it's
just a little drop it in and you're done
okay all right I'll leave it I'll leave
it on the table right here for anybody
that doesn't know not only is he an NBA
legend but he's
host of the hit podcast all the smoke
we're neighbors literally man we're
grateful to behaviors a wall I mean you
guys are with some big hitters I mean
you guys are made with us neighbors with
Mike Tyson I mean you guys are really
doing your thing congratulations thank
you thank you I'm the shortest and the
fattest dude in the room but I might be
the highest dude in the room
you're gonna be fighting with Mike for
that Mike's on another planet I I know
but I I got it straight weed probably I
think I was at the weed and dance I'm
like give me 15 minutes straight
mushrooms
I don't want to experience more than
eight grams I haven't gone more now I
don't want to eight grams at once yeah
that's like the most I'll ever do like
that's scary is Christ yeah but I mean
you know he's eating a bag yeah he just
eats them like handfuls he just eats
them like fruit nah I can't do that I
want my brain to stay intact
you know what I'm saying I get it so
I mean now that we talked about before
we started they're not testing for weed
anymore in the NBA were you smoking
before games yeah um when I started
smoking at 14.
um so going into my freshman year of
high school
um and for me it was an escape I had a
rough childhood you know my parents were
functioning drug addicts there's abuse
violence and
I was always looking for a way out you
know what I mean so I tried weed the
first time got a horrible headache took
a nap right on the spot and I came back
the next day like I'm not a quitter I'm
gonna get this ride and you know kind of
found my way and and I've used it since
then so all through high school all
through UCLA through my entire pro
career
um and when I say I smoke before games
it's not like I'm smoking on the way to
a game like we'll have a shoot around in
the morning for an hour or so I'll come
home smoke take a nap get up shower eat
and go to the game so it's within like a
you know three or four hour window I'll
smoke but all right so uh you said 14 14
also do you remember that experience who
were you with my little homeboy Jesse
and his brother his brother's the one
that got us the way he lived on our
street
got us the way this brother was like
17 or 18 maybe a senior in high school
and let us hit it
and uh a lot of coughing and again the
headache instantly went to sleep but
next day I was just like okay I'm not
gonna take as many hits this time let me
try it again it took a few hits and I
was cool and just kind of increased I
probably say my peak of smoking was man
probably like
2 000 like four to like nine
well while the fire was in California
yeah so that was kind of like my last
little run I had kids in 2008 so I had
to kind of slow down there but we were
heavy like my day would be I'd work out
I get up morning and work out and
probably between me and two or three of
my homies we smoked 40 50 60 blunts a
day how fat are your blunts 40 60 blunts
a day they were heavy you know because I
had money so we were blowing we were
rolling big boys so it may be three four
of us you're doing this one yeah just
just hanging out and it's burning but we
you know that's back when we passed it
around now now everybody smokes their
own you know I mean that used to be the
thing was we you know we played Madden
all day and just smoke weed and order
food we get too high we jump in the pool
and just keep the day going
that kind of leads into one of my
questions when you're established in the
league when you're a star you got your
contract you're an official dude in the
league how hard is your training day to
day like cardio strength training I
don't even think you have to be a star
to do it just to make it you have to do
it you know what I mean so it's it's a
four to six hours depending on who you
are you know what I mean I would get up
I normally running I would run in the
morning then I would do a weight session
and then you know you get shots up and
then if you play and then sometimes you
mix boxing in there or biking or
swimming so the way I look at it is just
like they were paying me a good amount
of money just to stay in shape so I'd be
done by one o'clock unless I went back
and played at night so I would have the
whole summer to just anytime after one
o'clock I do whatever I want so the
entire time so it's just it was a blast
and like I didn't take that for granted
are you like a distance Runner I love to
run well not anymore as much but yeah I
used to like to run that was how that
was the main way I stayed in shape I
always prided myself on being like one
of the most In-Shape guys like I always
like when they calculated how many
people like even with stars I wasn't
Star as a role player but who ran the
most miles this season I was always top
five top ten at every season so being in
shape was my thing and I used to love to
run that was my main thing I used to
laugh I don't think I've ever heard
anybody say I love to run
foreign
[Music]
shipping costs are the number one cause
of abandoned carts have you left the
cart because the shipping costs were too
expensive I know I have when using
shipstation you can lower shipping costs
make returns easy and keep your
customers happy as most of us know
running a business can be stressful but
with ship station it doesn't have to be
right now is the time to take advantage
with a quick setup and a free trial
shipstation makes it easy to grow your
business by handling all your orders
from different marketplaces and One
dashboard shipstation effortlessly
integrates everywhere you ship online
from Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify all One dashboard you
can manage every single thing about your
business from the shipstation dashboard
and that's One dashboard it'll always
find you the cheapest shipping price at
automate shipping tests it prints your
labels for you and it will give you the
best rates for your customers on the
shipping on top of that auto delivery
notification so you're not in the emails
just responding to every customer where
they're tracking is honestly for me to
you it makes everything easier no more
weighing every single package it
automates everything just so you can
print the label ship it out make money
with the best discount the industry
you'll never have to worry about
overpaying for shipping get up to 84 off
USPS and UPS rates with ship station if
that's not enough use our code dope as
usual for a free two months over 130 000
companies have grown their online
business using shipstation and 98 of
customers that stick with ship station
for more than a year become customers
for life 98 if you're a small business
owner like me keep it going ship station
just automates it makes life easier
makes the warehouse life easier just
trust me remember two free months quick
setup it's free try it out you have
nothing to lose
foreign
make Meal Time easy with fresh wholesome
ingredients delivered directly to your
door no lines no hassles just easy
healthy meals you can make from home
hellofresh makes it easy to eat healthy
all right these are dietitian approved
meals on some of the meals it'll say a
dietitian win that's a tag on some of
the meals that are under 700 calories
and have a third of the sodium as I said
they're not just junk food this is for
your life this is for your health and it
makes it easy with the cost of groceries
going up and up now is the perfect time
to get started with hellofresh
hellofresh is cheaper than grocery
shopping and 25 percent less expensive
than takeout if you're an entrepreneur
you know food is the last thing on your
mind when you're working and working
hellofresh makes everything easier right
no more going to the store like Marty
said waiting in long lines if you don't
know recipes like me e quesadillas all
the time all right hello fresh is going
to really help you plan out your meals
your families well balanced go to
hellofresh.com yola50 and use code Yola
50 for 50 percent off plus free shipping
remember hellofresh is America's number
one meal kit so take advantage of this
deal Yola 50. check out hello fresh.com
Yola 50 and that will get you 50 off for
your entire order plus free shipping
[Music]
he's about to run the OC Marathon my
wife are you still around the LA
Marathon I'm about to do it for the
first time oh wow yeah any any running
history or I mean I play basketball my
whole life but then I fell off right
when I like stopped playing basketball
yeah okay since November I've been
running and lifting and stuff so I'll
just drop like 30 35 pounds good luck
with that yeah thank you yeah our homies
just to the Ellie Marathon my wife to
the LA Marathon they're all potheads but
I just feel like if you could run 26
miles your body don't shut down your
monster absolutely I just I mean we see
now more than anything I mean
you could be functional with weed it's
always you know people have always known
that but it's been you know it hasn't
been talked about you know I think when
they started finding out some of their
favorite stars of the game [__] kind of
changed the whole narrative you know it
was such a Negative Gateway you loser
lazy and we're like I was thinking
before it was mainstream I'm just like
some of the best players in the world
are high right now dropping 35 getting
finals MVPs winning championships you
know what I mean so I just always said
like
as soon as the Superstar came out and
kind of endorsed it uh it would change
and I think shout out to my little you
know my brother Kevin Durant because
he's someone who kind of stepped in this
Lane and and really embraced it and it
hasn't been no real pushback
is great and it's like in culture to
where they're making jokes on Jimmy
Kimmel and she got weed and what I think
did it and even though it wasn't good
for him at the time I think when Michael
Phelps got caught with that picture what
started the conversation I think that's
what it was yeah like how many gold
medals you just win right it starts to
come out but he took a lot of [__]
though you got the worst of it come on
man actually Ricky Williams got the
worst of it oh okay we had him on last
season and then Michael Phelps was no
but I think on a world stage Michael
Phelps but I'm saying like kind of the
first kind of like Pro I feel like in
our space I feel like Ricky Williams
Nicholas yeah you're friends with the
Diaz brothers
yeah I would love to [__] with them
though I just never ran across them but
I've always been a huge fan of them dude
it's a huge fan of the Diaz brothers
we'll run across each other one day
eventually yeah it's gonna happen that
kind of leads into a question I have so
and you can pick yourself
which NBA player would make the most
seamless transition into MMA do you
think
oh man that's a great great joint I
appreciate that man appreciate it yes
that's seven leaves
get that
um
I just have a different understanding
and respect because it's a difference
between being able to fight being able
to box and then MMA like I have a such a
huge respect for every craft that like
I grew up fighting so that doesn't
necessarily mean that's going to trans
over great to boxing it definitely
doesn't Trend over to MMA you know what
I mean so I would have to say someone
who practiced uh they said James Johnson
is someone who was in uh you know into I
don't know what what what he practiced
but someone who's just kind of in that
space so I'd probably say him
um he'd probably be dope check him out
good answer I was always like wondering
I wish you could do like video games
like have LeBron in there Chew in there
like just see what happens Def Jam fight
yeah exactly come on yeah that's one of
the best games ever man look at that
[__] crossing over to some other [__]
yeah it sells come on you're not gonna
be like yo I'm a little baby and I'm
fighting Shaq yeah stop just crossing
over that'd be fun
someone needs to come up with that game
and we'll go now for real so yo I didn't
realize you grew up in this area all
right so
question since you're from that area
this is uh x-rated yeah x-rated Brother
Lynch sibo all right cool I wasn't sure
I just got the finals the other day oh
yeah I heard they were out yeah 24d or
oh watch out was it I can't remember I
just bought a couple I bought so many
records there's been some Talent from
sack mozzie yeah
you know he was we had him on all the
smoke
um he's chill I bet it before yes Zach's
got some Talent out there man but yeah
we listen we grew up listening to that
grew up listening to Master P that's
when Tru first came out that was kind of
like my junior senior year just had him
on the show right uh yeah we did that we
just had to have Master P so yeah but I
always listen to like whatever was in
our side I didn't really start listening
to like Jay-Z and other type of music
until I came to La out of college like
instead we listened to I had no money so
we listened to what was on the radio
whatever the homies had you know Jay-Z
yeah a few years ago yeah I never really
listened to it no I'm gonna be honest
right oh man I didn't have to understand
like if to me it was pox New Q like West
Coast side what I heard on the radio you
know what I mean so it's just like yeah
my eyes didn't really open up until I
came to college in like the late 90s out
here and that's when I started getting
all the other [__] whatever you want
okay I gotta say this was the best your
set is the best podcast walk in here and
see like those are we got the same top
yeah you know to walk in here and have
them on the walls like so legendary man
he stayed in here for how long Christine
he three separate overnight paint
he's a monster bro see a shadow ink one
but it was just
you know when I created all the smoke I
just wanted to to
create a this kind of vibe you know what
I mean like I feel like the best
conversation is like in the man cave
watching the game smoking and drinking
you know what I mean so if you can
capture and it doesn't you don't have to
be a celebrity to have those kind of
Vibes it's that's where the best men
conversations are at like not the
barbershop it's the man cave kicking
back burning one drinking so I wanted to
be able to create that kind of vibe but
just have cameras captured so you know
my goal was always to make a cool
environment so when people come in they
feel comfortable you know what I mean
and they feel comfortable enough to
share so
I just like I want to create this Vibe
and I just you know what do you want to
do I was like I want to put some people
on the wall you want to do it I found
this dude on Instagram I was just like
bro can you do this for our new podcast
and he came in and knocked that [__] out
and it just kind of we went from there
you know what I mean so
our first year we went Sports podcast of
the year like we didn't even know what a
podcast was six months before we started
you know what I mean so I mean we came
in here just kind of gangbusters but
because I feel like because we create
that kind of environment like if you
come up here on the shoot day like you
know these are these are our homies you
know what I mean so it's just like we
come kick back we smoke we drink we have
music we eat food and then we sit down
and talk and how long you guys been
friends for me and stack I've known him
since I came in the league but we became
brothers and like we we became teammates
in 2007 and we made NBA history when the
Warriors beat Dallas in the first round
that very next season my mom died at the
very beginning of the season and Jack
was just the one every day to come check
on me bring me food come smoke with me
yeah try to make me laugh so we went
from like new teammates we only
teammates for like eight months uh to
being like brothers so we've just been
rocking ever since damn what same [__]
same [__] last year really is well yeah
yeah that was sorry to hear that but
you've had so many Legends you've I mean
even outside of basketball obviously
with basketball you've had on Kobe
you've had on stuff you've had on Magic
Johnson Charles Barkley everybody but
you found out Will Smith Kevin Hart so
many people in music and just outside to
basketball has there been like an
episode that really stands out
it's so hard to pick a favorite as you
find such like to me it's just like I'm
I'm getting to interview my peers or or
people I look up to and I'm learning
more about them you know what I mean so
ever I take something from every episode
you know obviously you think we did
Kobe's last interview it was supposed to
be a two-parter because we only got four
like 40 men were the first times we were
supposed to do like a part two
um so that was obviously great Shannon
sharp was a dope episode I think that's
the our most viewed episode uh you know
then you [__] around and get a child
support you think about it we did Magic
Johnson Charles Barkley Isaiah Thomas
within like a six-week run geez like to
me there's no other show that gets the
talent but then gets the talent to open
up and that's what's special because you
know obviously there's so many different
platforms and everyone's doing
interviews these days like you know why
do people want to come to your show and
why do they feel like they open up so
much on your show you know so to me it's
all about the vibe it's cool people that
work here that that kick back and smoke
with us it's just to me I want to create
just a very comforting situation and you
know my favorite [__] is when I've never
told nobody this you know but I'm you
know I mean I mean that really makes me
feel like okay
they're [__] with us they're really
comfortable so that's kind of just been
my goal and um in this space and it's
been winning that's really the whole
point of what we did uh for our fans
because I on my like I said we met a lot
a long time ago but what I was doing
there was a I made the Wii company based
off of Quan and Tony and all those
because I had such a big following
online but what I did was just tell
stories right and I feel like now I mean
probably us we don't get it because we
went outside and rode a [__] bike and
went down the street to our friends but
a lot of people now
if you don't approach him or talk to him
they're not going to talk to nobody that
day like I feel a lot of people are just
such home buys or almost anti-social
just because that's where they were
brought up so I feel like shows like
this makes people feel like you know I'm
sitting right swearing out exactly and
I'm smoking I feel like they're my
homies so we do meet and greet you meet
people in person they're choosed right
love it because I guarantee you meet
people that are like yo love the NBA the
show love the show like everybody's all
the small I mean L.A so it's a Lakers
and then
but outside of that it's just like man
all the smoke all the smoke you know
what I mean we went to an All-Star game
I want to say in Chicago when it was out
there when I tell you it was you would
have thought they were screaming for us
like we were stars you know what I mean
it's just like neither of us knew we
weren't Stars you know I mean we were
stars in our roles but we you know we
know we know where we're at these
[__] were screaming for us you
know what I mean so to just seeing it
it's crazy too because you get it to all
different ages genders races it's it's a
beautiful thing that kind of just brings
everybody together so I agree it's very
important because we do live in a
society that's kind of technology driven
and very self-centered and then you know
you need to sit down laughing and be
able to smoke something and enjoy and
just man appreciate [__]
exactly exactly so question he got my
kids a PlayStation 5 for Christmas we
got 2K 23 so I'm like playing basketball
with my son now introducing him to every
era of all the places eight don't
smashing though so yeah it's tough he's
better he's it's tough
it takes me [__] but that leads us to
watching highlight reels we've been
watching not like Kobe all the different
highlight reels on YouTube and stuff and
about a week two weeks ago we were
watching the real of the infamous
yeah did you know because I was I was
trying to tell him because he's like
Kobe wasn't nice and I'm like being a
champion isn't about being nice it's
about being a leader being tough being
like a warrior out there and it's hard
for a kid to understand especially a
young kid tell him Kobe was a [__]
dog
um you know that moment was you know
it just happened you know I had so much
respect for him uh getting a chance to
see him his process coming up with me
being at UCLA while he was here and
getting a chance to meet him and kind of
just his Evolution as a player so I've
always was a huge fan and I just you
know remember I knew like thank you sir
if I get there he's going to be the
person I have to guard you know what I
mean so I just would always appreciate
that opportunity and it was just always
a competitive situation you know Kobe's
always going to score and my goal not
only with him but anybody was to make
him take he's gonna score 30 points make
him take 30 shots give him nothing easy
don't give him no and ones if you pump
fakes you too much follow his ass like
that's like because my with my kind of
approach when I guard it because every
night I guard the best players in the
world so that was kind of my repo uh
approach to it and people respected it
you know I mean that was my Lane like I
said I wasn't no star but I was the star
of my role like I knew exactly what the
[__] I had to do that's why no matter
whatever team I went to I either started
with I was like the first first or
second guy to come off the bench because
I just knew what my job was
um so the Kobe situation again just a
lot of respect and you know admiration
at the time but it was heading towards
the playoffs and
Kobe's just someone who is a you know
obviously physically to me he's the most
skilled player we've ever seen so he
always had that but then he would try to
just mentally [__] with you you know we
talked about it on our show like you
know
grab you album you do little dirty [__]
and they would never call it because
it's him yeah he would get away with
murder like album people is just like
insane so it just we're going back and
forth and
he had hit me with a few elbows and I
was just tired of like I was ready to
fight him and then I told him I was like
bro I want to fight you you know what I
mean and just so when the ball fake
happened it wasn't something like our
plan like I wanted to fight but that's
the reaction no I didn't I had no it was
like I was on autopilot my arms just did
it but if like if you look at me like we
had we were running to play for Vince
Carter so I was looking to get the Vince
the ball off the inbound so it just
happened and then that [__] like you
know
it was on his eyelashes and he didn't
blink but I think that changed his
impression of me because as soon as that
season ended
um I got a phone call from a number I
didn't know I happened to pick it up and
it was him and he just you know we
talked back and forth about you know
they had won the championship that year
and he asked what I was gonna
do the following year and I was you know
talking to Miami and
Toronto and he's just like you know
anyone crazy enough to [__] with me is
crazy enough to play with me he's like
do you want to be a Laker oh [__] hell
[__] yeah you know I'm from
NorCal so my I grew up you know magic
was it Showtime Lakers were everything
to me so
you know he uh she had invited me to
come be a part of his team and like four
days later I was a Laker so it went from
like but it went from uh an end in
moment incident to what you know what
what turned up in a short amount of time
me and like a real Brotherhood you know
I mean like we used to see each other at
you know coaching our kids he would come
watch my kids play we'd go watch him and
Gigi do their thing so it was just like
we grew as we went from you know
competitors to teammates to like
brothers like I [__] with code like he
used to
call me we coaching tournaments and uh
he said you know what time what time the
Twins play they play at nine what time
you play 11. it's like all right he
would come to watch eight year old at
nine a.m two hours before his game and
just stand there and show support for my
kids and their team and we were going to
do the same so I got a chance to see a
different side of like I said he was a
[__] dog but he was cool like once he
opened up if he allowed you to come in
um
great dude and I even asked him I was
like well how come you can't show the
world this kind of code
and he like pondered for a second he's
like no I can't show these [__]
that you know what I mean like he just
had his image of who he was and what he
was about and he was about that business
you know what I mean but I was you know
fortunate enough to be able to
see the man the Father the businessman
the creative mind the the the same
passion that drove him for 20 years in
the NBA he's you know he told me last
time he sat down he's like I don't want
to be remembered for basketball like I
want people to remember for my next 20
years you know and that's what kind of
grind and mentality he had so to be able
to see that on end off the court as a
competitor or teammate and then like I
said as a brother that was a really dope
opportunity you've played with so many
champions like was his like I like to
call a Killer Instinct see I was trying
to tell my son I played basketball out
of Buffalo my whole life but uh I was
too nice like I really didn't have a
Killer Instinct until I stopped playing
basketball I got into music right you
played with stuff you played with all
the grace is he the most locked in and
intense athlete absolutely that's a fast
ass answer too absolutely Kobe was
different I remember one time we were um
my first year with the Lakers we were
going to Spain in the summer or excuse
me in the preseason and it was the big
old planes with there's beds in there
and our families were there and
everything I don't know what time it was
but the whole plane was sleep and I get
it and I I was watching a movie and I
seen Cobra over there he was like three
worlds over but so he's way on the other
side but I just seen him bobbing his
head with headphones on so I was about
to go ahead and start talking [__] I
thought he was over there rapping or
something so like so I was about to go
and start talking my [__] not again but
when I go over there
he's got a piece of scratch paper with
like 30 different little quartz on it
I'm just like what the [__] this dude
doing it's like what is this he's just
like I'm watching he's like when they're
guarding me
I know I'm gonna take three guys so I'm
gonna take the guy guarding me I never
look at the guy guarding me I'm looking
at helps the two help sides
he's like so within this I'm trying to
see where you Lamar fish
pal and buying them Mata where you guys
are all going to be open at
so he just was playing like on different
parts of the Court every part of the
Court he would have the defense shifted
to him and seeing where we can get open
at
okay like what the [__] but he was over
there jamming like I said I thought he
was rapping and I get over there and he
has all these little quartz and looks
like scribbled everywhere but he was
really breaking down here this is you
when this happens here you can do that
I'm just like whoa like I was asleep man
yeah no but it just it blew me away it
just showed like he's like everyone else
asleep and I'm you know and it just
showed like he's it was like a beautiful
mind like he wanted to be the best and
he did everything he could like his big
thing was winning that six rings like I
want to be able to sit at the table with
MJ you know and won six so that was his
biggest drive but that [__] I've
never seen no one her no no one
work as hard as him but another die man
I gotta transferred Alan Iverson he was
a killer
um super killer little dude
and little by you means he's six foot my
height but he's a little prepared to
going against you know I was a child I
was a kid like yeah she's so small and
then I saw his stats when I was a kid
watch like he's a little not little like
that I mean compared to Mexican ass my
family
he'd be a giant with your people but he
was he was little in the league but yeah
that's what I was gonna say like always
beat up the big burst of sex on his
elbows that's why he wore those sleeves
to keep them up I was wearing the
bruised hips like he walked like an old
man but every night he would get out
there and work you know what I mean but
he was little
who else who else who else and Jack
Barron was a killer
um CP3 was a killer
staff KD
clay Dre everyone in their own way it's
like I got a chance to play play with
Shaq Steve Nash
uh who else Vince Carter primed Dwight
Howard
incredible he's like incredible Shannon
sharp of the NBA
but bigger but bigger yeah
when I played with him in Orlando he was
incredible like I played with a lot of
like he's the top of my list as far as
great players I play with
um yeah man I was blessed to play you
know Chris Webber who's your greatest
white boy of all time just J will white
chocolate J Will Sacramento and then uh
my guy JJ read it yeah I [__] with JJ I
didn't think I like JJ and we it was
funny we talked about on his podcast
because he I don't I think he said he's
like I didn't I wasn't sure about you I
was like I just didn't think I would
like you because you know all the dude
guys have that kind of Duke like cocky
yeah image like I was cool Grant Hill
because that was one of my favorite
players but that's the rest of the Duke
dudes I always kind of looked at like
this like I think the league kinda
so we teamed up for the first time in
Orlando and it was just like brother
separated bird like I [__] with JJ and
then we played together uh you know with
the Clippers too so someone I didn't
even think I would like is probably one
of my closest
you know if you can have them like post
NBA friends because I don't have many
but uh I definitely [__] with Jay
Jackson one guy you don't have many I
don't surprised to hear you say that
yeah I'm cool with a lot of people but
like actual yeah I get it I don't it's
just too much in here I got a big fan I
got six kids you know what I mean and
and a fiance and I work I love to work
but I work a lot so I just don't really
have time for it like you know we really
[__] with each other we always catch up
at some point yeah every couple months
yeah
and just like whenever we see we picked
up like we just saw you yesterday so
that's you know those are the kind of
friends I have so I could probably count
that on you know outside of my college
homeboys NBA guys probably maybe five
guys like that yeah so she gets to
interview people with like your best
friend and [__] it's like us dope man
that's exactly and you know of all
people but think like I was saying with
your peers like you're saying I don't
think anybody else has gotten these
people on the same time it's because
when you look at somebody like yeah
you're me let's [__] it's different
because now with podcasting as as fans
because you're even fans of certain
people you bring on the show of course
you're like oh I can't wait to hear this
[__] yeah and maybe maybe not all the
time you're like geeking out but the
interview is uh you learn uh but like
that's the coolest part you learn so
much about people you already admire you
know I mean your peers you get to learn
you know really more about them and I
think that's what's kind of helped me
because there was such a stigma who I
was you know I mean when I play because
people would see me on TV for two and a
half hours I might slap somebody cuss a
rough out get kicked out of the game you
know he's an [__] he's a thug he's
this he's that but I was just a
competitor yeah I knew what my job was I
would smoke weed and go play basketball
like it doesn't get better than that you
always have to hide the weed like
childhood all the way up not in I didn't
hide I mean like it was illegal in the
NBA so I wouldn't let nobody know you
know I mean I had a couple of teammates
I would smoke with here and there but it
wasn't like I was out there freely
smoking because we couldn't can I tell
you my most embarrassing basketball
moment maybe you can think of one
summer league I graduated at 17. I
wasn't even uh that good I was like I
played my whole career I'm way more of a
playground player than for school so I
was the only kid on the team that went
on to play college basketball just off
hard work alone
so I'm in summer league the only white
kid on the team I'm the youngest by far
I got my girlfriend in the stands all
these dudes are hollering at her in the
stands I'm like cognizant of that I'm on
the bench like just trying to get some
play time and like on my team we were D2
at the time there was grown men out
there you know like you could be going
to play college but there's like 30 35
year old men out there
and they want to sub me in he went to
sub me in for the center or Center's his
house he goes to sub man we're losing
it's like late in the game I'm like
almost thinking like bro you're putting
me in
you wouldn't come out they're going to
sub me in I go to walk in the dude's
like [__] that [__] that I'm not come
doesn't come out and I'm just like
all right
give me air five I got you bro that was
horrifying that's [__] up that's a bad
feeling I couldn't imagine that
I don't know
coach anyone else you want to try to set
me in for this motherfucker's not coming
out anyone else you want something
before
uh embarrassing moment in the NBA oh
yeah I remember one time in a Miami game
um
Nelly was being an [__] I went from
playing a lot to not playing at all and
he stopped me in at the end I think we
were blowing him out
and somebody pumped I'm not sure if it
was d-wave but someone pump faked me and
I just tripped on the pump fake and like
ran past him and like fell down
Jack and baron always tell this story
but that was probably my most
embarrassing moment I've been dunked on
and that kind of [__] but to me
it's all on camera yeah I'm not
embarrassed on that [__] yeah I mean
like it's just the whole world you know
watching it's forever yeah now people
get dunked I'm not tripping off that but
he made me he made the shot fake got me
stumbling all right so [__] it I got one
basketball one I loved basketball as a
kid if I were to throw it out there you
know and one of my whole [__] I can
dribble you know I could dribble really
well other than that like bro just just
pass it
I'm not gonna [__] lay up on these
Giants uh anyway I went to go try for
basketball I'm you know I'm starting
every single sport I'm a [__] cat
it's another line every sport I play my
oh hell yeah I'm good in sports
wrestling [__] fools up go to
basketball because I'm at school I'm
doing the the hot sauce [__] wearing a
big shirt oh juking fools throwing it to
Andre and he just man like perfect team
and I I suck other than that I'm like
I'm gonna go right I feel like your
energy reminds me of like a Chris Farley
when he tries to do [__] all right yeah
okay I can see myself falling down the
hill
I take that as a complex yeah all right
so uh yo I'll go try out for basketball
seventh grade I'm like all right bam my
homie Anthony he's big as [__]
and I'm like don't be a ball hog because
he's on the playground I'm a [__]
ball hog because I just want to get
somebody to fall you know it's and one
that's all we do we got the tapes of the
flea market
I have no shoes I'm wearing [__]
Converse but like I'm gonna shoot the
[__] out of these fools all right low
cuts no always high tops I don't [__]
with the lows dude I like pair of green
lows I never wore highs I always [__]
with the lows I can't do I just look I
was just a little short fat kid so I'm
like hello just made me look like a nerd
so you feel like you got a little bit of
protection in the high voice a little
bit more confidence yeah the sale I'm
like oh those times make sense and he
looks sick he can jump high Benny the
bullet yeah all right so here we go I'm
like don't be a ball hog I go and I'm
just passing it being cool passing it I
dribble a couple times lay up I make I'm
like all right these are tryouts I never
tried for basketball I go to the thing
the next morning names are on the list
didn't make it I go to the coach like
you just don't take the ball initiative
enough and you just pass too much I
wouldn't give me and I was it so I went
from don't be a Baja I didn't make this
a fine line um haven't you made it
who told you don't be above I taught
myself oh don't be a ball hog this is a
team sport this is a real school you
would have gave me your mixtape you
probably thank you you never know
that's all I could do to this day yeah I
suck does that go through your mind like
even in your earlier days like I want to
not look like a ball hog but I need to
get my shots off I'm trying to go up the
ranks no you just kind of I mean you got
to figure out what your position is on
the team you know I mean everyone wants
to come in and be a scorer but you know
you may be good at scoring it on a
certain level but when there's just
levels of scoring you know what I mean
so I just kind of adapted I went from
you know averaging nearly 30 points and
you know triple double in high school to
like in college in the low teens to the
NBA I was like 10 11. you know I mean I
just found out what my role was yet why
would I wanted to shoot more and score
more but that just wasn't what my role
was my role was to play defense you know
what I mean rebound and do you know have
do you know who David Goggins is I don't
he's like one of the greatest endurance
athletes alive uh but he has a really
good book out and he was talking about
when he played basketball he's like
there's always room on the floor for the
best defensive player
period but to me I mean there's there's
room on the floor to just to play hard
because it's kind of like a lost art you
know what I mean so to you know my role
I play defense he might Dove on the
floor I got rebounds I mean you know I
made fouls I made hard fouls if needed
you know
me to do so when I got my shots you know
I would knock them down but I just
figured out what the [__] I had to do
and and made a career out of it I was
the most talented by far I just you know
probably had the most heart I mean it
was gonna do whatever it took two
to last so I just kind of take that
mentality into business now you know
exactly that's why in business I'm
moving as if I was in all like a 10-time
All-Star you know I mean those are kind
of getting the same deals and
opportunities and [__] running shows
that those kind of guys get so it's like
Nori like Nori wasn't ever the biggest
rap star in the world but now he's
established his Landing podcasting he's
the biggest [__] or something yeah it's
a whole other side and people don't ever
get to see yeah you know like you said
people finally get to see I'm not an
[__] yeah you know I get to do
different sides though too because
obviously all the smoke we can do this
but then I'm on ESPN that's Disney you
know what I mean so there's a certain
way I gotta move and talk and although
they're a lot looser now that's just not
who I really am you know what I mean and
then on the flip side I commentate games
so that's a whole nother side that I
have to kind of give so I it's dope that
I get to do this with the homies and
then I also have to put the tie on and
do this and then I get to talk about the
game you know what I mean so there's a
bunch of different Lanes so
I want to use that like ultimately to
like be like a daytime talk host like
not about sports but just kind of like
on the Michael Strahan type [__] just
someone that's just well versed across
several different platforms and they
could bring people together and can get
people to open up and and really talk
you know so that's kind of my goal of
doing all this [__] because I'm I'm
gonna get tired of doing all this [__]
like I want to be able to focus yeah
you know but until that till I feel like
it's gonna happen I'll continue to you
know mix it here mix here and mix here
and mix here mix here but it's all fun
[__] you know I mean I get paid to like
smoke weed and interview the most
amazing people in the world I get paid
to talk about sports you know what I
mean so it's just like she lucked out
again right it's it's a lot and I travel
a lot and I move a lot but it's come up
man I got to play basketball for a long
time and now I could talk about
basketball than other sports until I
don't want to do it no more like come on
man you kidding me
you couldn't ask for more I got to be
honest because we talk about post life
post being an athlete what do you do
that's the biggest part of your life
you're only an athlete for a small
portion of your life yeah you gotta
think the average professional career is
you know less than three years you know
is it really yeah less than three less
than three what was it like after 17
year I believe pro career no I was uh
15. 15. um it was it was cool like you
know I signed
I assigned a three-year deal going into
that last season not knowing it's gonna
be my last season but I ended up you
know I was in Sacramento I was gonna go
finish with my hometown team
um and then Midway through the season
they decided to trade DeMarcus Cousin so
I just you know I talked to the
management so I'm you know too old to
try to start over
you know you know I want to go too like
okay you know we're gonna go young right
now anyway so perfect so they let I get
let go but they still have to pay me the
rest of my contract and then I get a
chance to go play with the Warriors
um with KD and staff and clay and Trey
and the last half of the season and and
you know end up winning the championship
so I just decided to kind of step away
from basketball you know I I was still
being paid for two more years
I wanted to be more present with my kids
because my twins were growing up and I
was going through a lot not really being
able to see him at the time so I like I
I walked away from the game
um so I was ready you know I mean so I
was lucky and then right from there
fumbled on some TV like I was big in the
Cannabis space you know so that's where
I kind of the first thing I jumped into
um out of retirement kind of wanted to
be the shield for current players so you
know myself out here until we're going
out and meeting with the mbpa and the
NBA talking about them you know you guys
need to study this and there's benefits
from this this and that you know get
your you know get some people to
research it and
went back and forth with that for a long
time and then I went to the space but
then you know shortly after I stumbled
on media and kind of made a lane for
myself there and I haven't looked back
I've never thought like damn I still
want to play or damn I wish I I love it
I talk about it I go to the games I
coach my kids games
um but I just appreciate you know the
run I had like luckiest you know
luckiest man in the world I mean I could
play 15 years and then like again now
retired I get to be me tatted up on ESPN
they know I smoke weed you know what I
mean it's just like kidding me people
are still people see me everywhere you
know so it's just I don't I don't take
that for granted it's just such a
tremendous blessing and
I think because I just always been me
like there's no [__] with me like
once you get to know me like you might
see again people thought I was a certain
way but they get a chance to know me
hear me talk they're like oh okay
he's a pretty cool [__] you know
what I mean so it's just like this is
how I am most the time I'm always you
know if you're around me I smoke and I
handle my business and I'm a father you
know that's my life so
are you a weed snob with it are you real
particular in strains and stuff I just
smoke seven leaves most of the time I'm
not gonna lie to you you know we have a
nice little we got about 11 different uh
strains so
I smoke my own [__] most of the time but
I'm always open to try you know you know
what's given to me but uh
no I just I'm simple you know I know
what gets me high and yeah yeah keep
going I'm not like a it's it's not that
I never got to it's an art now you know
what I mean I'm just an old school let
me just smoke my weed and yeah yeah I
don't need to know know a whole bunch
about it I just need to know how it
makes me feel yeah yeah yeah
he goes I I don't know what it is I've
been smoking it yeah yeah that's what
are you smoking I don't [__] know I'm
not one of the ones gonna give you the
breakdown I'm just gonna tell you that
yeah that [__] got me high exactly that
[__] I want to switch this up real quick
I know you have some notes what's your
favorite three movies of all time Friday
series is one as a whole
um Friday okay damn you can put comedies
on another top three yeah but if you're
gonna go all three all right
so for no no those are no I'm just
saying that no no it has one yeah
um paid in full good [__]
New Jack City all right or Above the Rim
like one of those three something yeah
yeah
all right great answers I was I didn't
give you three I gave you like six yeah
you get where my mind was because I was
gonna I went to look up like I was
thinking about my top favorite
basketball movies
and then I realized because I was going
to ask like here's my top five what's
your top three or whatever but then I
realized there's so many great
basketball movies that I didn't realize
like I had to go to top ten it's hard to
narrow let me let me throw a couple
actions I'm sure I forgot about [__]
yeah all right He Got Game loving
basketball above the ram Basketball
Diaries Coach Carter white man can't
jump six-man Space Jam Celtic Pride
Hoosiers hoop dreams damn damn for me
yeah I guess so yeah they play a little
basketball was that with Leonardo oh you
good [__] most people go what is that
yeah basketball movies are dope yeah he
got game it's probably
the one I love White Men Can't Jump I
think Kenya Bears redid White Men Can't
Jump they're uh it's coming up yeah oh
is it I guess that oh it does when is it
uh this year I know that's all I know he
told us I don't know sometimes like next
summer love it
um and then Above the Rim obviously um
what'd you think about Ray Allen He Got
Game as like one of the that's probably
the biggest player who's been in a role
that biggest role right he was solid in
the role too like he perfect they can't
you know they cut that who was who that
was it they said the movie was about
stuff on Marbury I think so yeah I was
like Coney Island no Ray Allen was born
in Atwater right by Merced I didn't know
that yeah at the base interesting yeah
every time I look over myself like Ram
we learned something new home of Ray
Allen home of Ray Allen right there by
the flea markets
we talked about the trucks but
throughout your career on and off what's
been your favorite shoe Chucks oh I went
through a phase I mean it's always been
Chucks because I'm just straight west
coast but
um Air Force Ones for a long time I
probably had went through like a
thousand pair Air Force Ones
in the time where you couldn't have
scuffs on them so if you they said Nelly
look what you did to everybody you go
and buy like white like 15 or 30 of
those at a time especially if they got
the 14
Bears you said yeah
hold up we got old guy they'd get him
yeah because you just this is always
made him be a career though yeah okay
that's there I was like yeah what were
you doing
I had I had Payless Shoes until I was in
high school then I used to get like one
good pair of shoes a year and I would
always pop the air sole like six months
into school and then go back and
exchange them I did that all through
high school that was my how to how to
keep a pot you know oh and they'll get
those exchange to exchange them how do
you pop this with a little Neil yeah
we like we really did like it it took my
mom like to buy me a hundred dollar pair
of shoes
and it was only me she wouldn't give my
brother and sister not like you had one
pair this year after that back to these
14.99 [__] you know what I mean
so I've just I would take care of them I
would clean them up and then like you
know halfway through school I popped
them [__] and have a fresh pair
for the last run of school so I had a
little that was my little hustle and
those slant shoes at Payless they just
brought me back [__] up cause remember
they used to they used to look like all
the they used to look like the Jordans
like the the pages yeah they look like
them oh you get three pair of them
[__] for 39 just like
do Payless [__] held it down when I
was a child oh for damn sure I got those
light up La gears when I was a kid okay
at all all right speaking the same kind
of time frame
first car favorite car first car was a
Lincoln Town Car with velvet interior
and me and my friends were [__] like
we were doing jackass [__] before like
and then jackass came on right like we
were in high school so we knew we were
on to something like we used to like run
into each other with our cars or just
like like no breaks like not going hella
fast but we would like Coast into our
friends like 10 miles an hour and just
blast our whole front so
but I had a big town car so my [__] was
Heavy they had like Honda Accords yeah
you know I used to move when you go over
the bumps but someone banged the corner
of my [__] so
we and we couldn't I had no money to get
it fixed so like I used to have to hold
the door closed in my arm because it
they they banged it so it wouldn't
[__] shut all the way that's all you
have your [__] around I'm not paying
for that [__] so I had to ride that [__]
for a minute like would hold the doors
closed while I'm driving did you ever
tie it no I didn't deny just uh every
time I just stick my arm out though I
just got used to it it was what it was
people see me driving down the street my
door used to freeze open in the winter
yeah
uh favorite car that was my first my
favorite
ah
I was always pretty simple to be honest
with it was always benzes and and
Cadillacs uh Escalades but then I had a
Ferrari for a couple years that was
pretty dope you fit in that [__] yeah
California if you take the back seat out
not with the bag you've just screwed off
so you scoop the seat all the way back
yeah wow yeah that was shocked right now
man yeah what's your you want to talk
about your predicament and what you're
waiting on oh man I'm wearing my damn
car for like
it's almost five months four and a half
months and tomorrow's the day they said
what kind of car it's a it's a new it's
the Maybach the oh the the s680 it's the
first one it's the first one in America
four months ago when they said it's
landed and they just just signed it off
Friday every couple days a few more
weeks so I just been sitting here Carlos
for three weeks now because I sold my
other car so that's why I'm just sitting
here and I've got the mothership coming
in huh what color is it it's all black
but I'm gonna I'm gonna pick up plans
for it we're happy yeah I'm so
congratulations yeah thank you I'm just
waiting patiently waiting yeah
ubering that's a pretty big difference
no it's getting uh switching subjects
real quick it's getting towards the end
of the season obviously you work for the
Kings you're kind of biased or doing
good this season what's your forecast
for like the finals I'm excited I think
it's gonna be really good the West is
tight super tight you know three games
separate four to out of the playoffs so
plans are going to be good Sacramento's
having a really good year a really good
year I'm happy for him I'm from there
obviously it's been 16 years since I've
made the playoffs so I'm really happy
for him but I'm also realistic
um I just think this is going to be a
great first experience the only way
you're going to get better and continue
to climb is to get your feet wet so
I can see Sacramento
getting through the first round and and
you know making some noise in the second
round I'm not someone that's going to
say because I work for them I think
they're going to win a championship like
I'm I'm you know realistic but I think
they have a great chance they get hot I
think their ceiling could be the Western
Conference Finals to be honest with you
if they got hot because that's how
talented they are
um but then you look at Phoenix with
Kevin Durant coming back and Aiden
coming back they're going to be tough
um I don't really know how I feel about
Denver
I like that you're you're kind of like
the the person that passes the shots
around you just do the joints
I like that yeah casually thank you yeah
um Clippers if Paul George comes back
they got a chance
um and you can never count out Golden
State
um Eastern Conference I like
Milwaukee
I think they're the best team in the NBA
right now
Boston
and then the Dark Horse I think will be
Philly so
I've had to pick two teams to go to the
finals I would say it's going to be
I want to say Boston but I have to go
Milwaukee
versus
Phoenix
in the finals okay the official
production is completely off subject
growing up in Sacramento what was the
first concert you ever went to without
your parents I've never really to be
honest with you I didn't I probably been
to I'm not gonna lie to you maybe four
concerts my whole life
for real
do you just not like the vibe no I love
every time I go I'd just rather
chill at the house
oh [__] I mean damn truly rather just
yeah I just feel like you know and this
is not to sound any certain way like
I don't have fun going out to sporting
events because it's it's constant take
pictures autographs and it's never you
really ever get a chance to chill
um you know if you're doing some
backstage [__] you know that's something
I'll go to but outside of that I'd
rather just you know never been a huge
concert person even when I was younger
we didn't have the money to do it back
then but when I got you know when I got
the ability to go to concerts I remember
I've been to a Kanye concert I've been
to a Jay-Z concert
Snoop
might be missing one Tony Tony oh wow by
the way they're going on demo maybe a
little too uh how old are you 36 33 okay
yeah
they're going on tour they're going to
I'm excited for me yeah they're going on
tour so
yeah I've never been a big concert man
sorry to have a I actually so I went to
contact so I went to a Kanye concert in
Sacramento when I was playing for the
Kings in like 16 and he did it remember
when he was doing those like those 10
minute sets and he would leave oh
remember when he's on his [__] and
he wouldn't finish shows and he would
leave like he left oh yeah what 2016
what does that do oh no no I was yeah
yeah but he was on a on a Vibe where he
would finish up sometimes not in the
shows he did like 10 10 20 minutes at
the Sacramento show and then bounce
I'd be saying we're like what the [__]
yes are you kidding me you went to four
shows and one of them was a quarter of a
show it was dope though why it went
it was the good 20 minutes yeah I missed
that I missed that NBA like how
I'm just trying to imagine how they
would deal with like security it was
like with all the John Moran issues and
everything like do they ask you to kind
of be low-key do like how did they they
expect you to carry yourself a certain
way yeah that's hard sometimes you know
what I mean especially in you know job
rants situation you know 23 year old one
of the up and coming faces of the league
200 million dollar contract new shoe
deal
he probably just lost touch without
reality a little bit probably felt
Invincible you know what I mean but who
can blame him at that you know at that
point and I think he uh he has a new
appreciation because he realizes the
game can be taken away from him I don't
think he thought I thought he he thought
he was invincible
that nothing was gonna um can you
educate me did he just take a picture
with a gun is that all it was over no oh
no I don't really know a lot about you
yeah I think that was the kind of the
the the the the stamp but he had a
run-in of you know a couple different
situations like in like a maybe like a
two or three month span they would just
you never want your outside [__] to be
louder than and that's saying a lot
because he is so talented so you never
want the outside noise to be louder than
you are you know more noise than you're
making on the court but it was like he
was doing [__] that he just shouldn't
have been doing so you know luckily he
had an opportunity to write his wrongs
and and realize the game can be taken
away at any moment and I think he has a
new appreciation for it so
but the answer question it's just on you
you got to move the right way if you
feel like you need security take
security you know I mean I would never
tell someone not to use a gun I like
carry a gun you know because there's
just just a crazy world but
you know you if you're gonna pull it you
you know I was taught if you're gonna
pull it you have to use it yeah you know
what I mean it's not for show or likes
or comments you know I mean so it's just
like you know to each his own everyone
have you know something to say but my
thing was I just you know hope he gets
an opportunity to right is wrong and
correct yourself and understand because
to me he's
incredible like
a future face to the league that's how
good this kid is so I'm happy that he's
back on track and
you know helping his team get to the
playoffs
oh yeah me too it's not a question
first time I think I was four and I was
married I told the story I was watching
beauty and beast my homies and these
fools try to jump me it was my first
fight I ever got into yeah I was like
four or four years old in Fresno these
kids all try to beat the [__] out of me
I kicked him right in the dick there you
go and I ran kicked him and take away
there's so many kids I just ran do you
remember the first fight you ever got
into
you have to remember yeah and the thing
is sorry we're going into this as we're
normal sized people growing up you're no
I wasn't I wasn't I was a bigger kid but
I wasn't like way bigger than everyone
else like there was kids my size still
when did you get shot I probably Senior
High I went from like 5 10 to 6'4 over
that from eighth grade to uh I started
ninth grade so you're already like
chilling listening to your own kind of
music kind of age and [__] yeah gotcha
are you Center in high school though no
it was hard yeah I handle the ball so
so do you remember that first fight yeah
so I mean I had a bunch of fights when I
was young but I'm I'm talking about like
my first real fight I felt like outside
of my neighborhood was like when I was a
fourth grader against a sixth grade kid
and he sucker punched me and got me like
got me a nice knot like a little knot
came up but I chased him down and beat
the [__] out of him but um that was like
my first fight like outside of like my
family or cousins or kids in the
neighborhood was this over there has to
be something I don't remember was it we
were playing kickball and some [__]
happened like I don't know I think maybe
didn't agree or something and I thought
we were gonna walk up and push each
other he'd walk up and just took off on
me and got me
so I oh I whooped his ass but yeah he
got me my like my very first like
introduction to fighting like outside of
like I said my area oh yeah but I won
though real actual fight but a bunch of
ones in the neighborhoods and that's a
little happy spot there you fight all
the time like I grew up fighting but
yeah see the thing is I grew up well
obviously you know Merced what is it's
[__] gang Town drug town and I was
the only one that I wasn't fighting all
the time because I was just like oh
that's Thomas you just you know yeah I'd
rather I'd rather I'd rather do other
[__] you're not playing in the creek
playing outside we play all kinds hell
yeah The Creeks were fun well you're
from the all right you go to The Creeks
you ever build those the the bike jumps
oh yeah absolutely yeah the whole little
bike jump area a little bike gang I
asked this question to myself uh during
the pandemic and I just thought it was
funny that we brought it up on the show
if 16 year old version of you walks in
it's like yo I'm gonna beat the shadow
are you winning right now or a 16 year
old version are you winning I don't know
what my 16 year old has there it is but
I would I would try to talk him out of
it first
at first yeah that's that's the first
one yeah wise answer yeah the first like
yes the first I'll educate them all
right so I just it's a real thing it's a
great question because when I was in 16
I used to do uh competition like uh
weights and [__] so I was like a little
I beat the [__] out of myself I wouldn't
lose right now bro but hopefully we'll
change that see I was lucky like I
didn't we grew up fighting you know what
I mean like we didn't
we did it wasn't about no guns I mean we
there was a couple you know parties that
shot the ring off but I didn't I was
blessed that I didn't you know it was
all it was here so that's what it was so
I'm glad it wasn't though
question I like to ask if we could look
at your lifetime
listening like Spotify lists who would
be at your all-time most listened to
throughout your lifetime
it's not even close yeah it's probably
me too legendary what about a favorite
album for me it's Machiavelli album
makaveli's dope all eyes on me is dope
um yeah it's hard with him I mean that's
why he's you know he was the first one
we did on the ball
I think pocket big are like my two like
kings I don't even count them as
like they say great like I kept them out
of it because to me they're the greatest
and what they accomplished in such a
short amount of time you can imagine if
they had some were able to have some
longevity like the things they could
have did alive would be incredible for
music
um
yeah it would definitely be pop though
yeah he's 25 when he died you never
really think about that like a 25 year
old I think I thought about that when we
talked about it I was like I'm 30 what
yeah that was a child big he died on my
16th birthday really March 1996.
my 16th birthday
yeah
uh what's been your favorite era in the
NBA we talk about like the 96 era music
and movies and everything but to me the
greatest era is the 90s
I think music Sports overall NFL too
yeah I just wouldn't matter the most I
think 90s are the dumbest
um
NBA
I like the 80s
okay because I'm just more of a I was a
football player playing basketball so I
would I would have loved to be able to
play like
with the lame beers and the rambises and
to be able to really hard foul someone
or even swing on them and just
be like I would have loved I think that
happened you know what I mean to really
get a chance to obviously compete at
that level but if you just happen to
thumb you happen to throw me you're not
it's not going to cost a hundred
thousand dollars
I know that's why I never swung first
like if you press me and swung on me but
I'll push you out of my way or something
like that but that first swing oh it's
gonna cost you it's 100 no matter what
if you swing somebody I don't know what
it is but it's
ugly because I know I've got I've got
the 30 or 35 000 pushing fine so I can
only imagine if I would have swung
pushing that's so crazy getting getting
fined that cause of money oh I saw the
dude you just got fined for doing this
the money thing to the ref you see that
uh Luca he like he's like looked like he
got filed or whatever and he came up he
did this to the ref and they find him
like 35 000 or something for gesturing
to the rough like that I didn't see that
have you ever I didn't see that either
had any experiences where you're like
these refs are [__] oh yeah I had a
lot of technical fouls a ton of them I
had Pro I had over half a million dollar
in fines when I was in the name oh they
just take it out your check you don't
even get to see it it's like it never
came like you never touched it
yeah hell could you imagine yo every
time you cuss Nashville on the tables
should come up light
no I'll be pissed but then again I get
it all right you're basically playing
that game for free if you swing on
somebody
well not really but you know what I'm
saying yeah all right all right all
right all right do you have anything
else you wanted I think we hit all of
our announce here yeah we had a we had a
good little run right now yes thank you
this is legendary we appreciate it thank
you
um for everyone out there how can they
find you online it's just I know it's
Matt Barnes across all platforms yeah
Matt underscore Barnes nine on Instagram
all the smoke you can find us there you
find me on ESPN you can find me does it
feel weird saying all these things now
as you know I love it you find me on NBC
NBC and I mean I just I love being able
to be on multiple platforms kind of you
know carving my little niche in each so
who would you like who would be your top
picks for Gus on the podcast if you
could have anybody oh good question
Jay-Z
love to pick his brain
um Drake
maybe Michelle Obama
oh you guys that's a good pig yeah I
don't think LeBron's ever done a podcast
has he yeah man I would love to get
LeBron I feel like LeBron kind of want
and I'm not even mad at him like he's
got his own platform you know I mean so
why would I go get my dope [__] to and I
get it because that content is it's it's
a game it's a business now but hopefully
I hope one day I've seen him at
draymond's wedding he said he was coming
on so oh hopefully we'll be able to
catch him at some point be so sad yeah
oh my God Dan DeVito oh MJ MJ oh MJ okay
yeah yeah it's kind of kind of something
you like come on man do us a favor just
put the cigar down for a second for the
culture of Just Sports and yeah that's
one that's kind of just the queen they
need it yeah so man thank you so much
for reading I appreciate it fellas thank
you appreciate you guys on the smoke
show time oh what what day do you drop
all the smoke every Thursday we draw I
think we're dropping depending on when
this is coming out we just dropped
Isaiah Thomas uh coming this Thursday so
check us out uh but go to uh all the
smoke it'll tell you when it's coming
appreciate you being here Marty thank
you sir we really appreciate it
appreciate you man thank you guys this
has been the dope as usual podcast thank
you so much for being here for Marty
from Matt Barnes and I have a dope ass
day I'm high
I'm not gonna lie to you guys
yeah
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show tell a homie